rocard a démissionné qui sait à sa place
et décret sans 15 mai 1991 il ya presque
trente ans c'est une première en france
edith cresson est nommé premier ministre
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que cette nouvelle n'a pas été du goût
de tout le monde
d'abord au sein même de l'assemblée
nationale à peine nommé edith cresson
est déjà la cible d'attaqués misogyne
à l'image du député udf françois
d'aubert qui la compare à la marquise de
pompadour maîtresse du roi louis 15 et
là vraiment on est dans un système
incroyablement monarchie regardez le
parcours de madame de pompadour
regardait le parcours d'edith cresson il
ya un parallélisme certains autres
remarques sexistes toujours à
l'assemblée nationale le 22 mai 1991
edith cresson présent son discours de
politique générale l'hémicycle devient
le théâtre de quolibets sexiste des
propos rapportés par l'ex député ps
denise cacheux en 1999 j'ai entendu des
députés derrière moi dire elle n'est pas
m'a foutu etc
crois tu que l'un a slip je me suis
retourné pour leur demander s'ils en
avaient un machisme à l'assemblée mais
aussi dans la rue encore une fois
edith cresson n'échappe pas aux clichés
[Musique]
misogynes
présent je la vois bien meilleure je
vois bien la nouvelle première ministre
est attaqué de partout dans les journaux
le quotidien de paris titre matignon
mais aussi à la télévision dans
l'émission satirique le bébête show
edith cresson est représentée par la
marionnette à ma botte l'accompagnent
docile de ker mitterrand je lis les
journaux et je me marre tu te voir un
coach m'a fait voir quand tu que marc
pendant toute la durée de son mandat
la socialiste a été victime de sexisme
elle démissionne le 2 avril 1992
cinq ans plus tard en 1997 edith cresson
revenait sur ce machisme ambiant
politique ce que vous voulez faire ne
les intéresse pas finalement c'est ce
que vous êtes
la couleur de votre tailleur comment
vous être coiffée
votre voix votre façon de soutenir c'est
ça ce sont des détails qui sont liées à
la personne et ça ça s'identifie au
racisme le sexisme
c'est la même chose que le racisme et du
pression reste à ce jour en france la
seule femme nommée première ministre
[Musique]